una araña común tiene ocho ojos tiene
ocho ojos si una araña te está viendo
con sus dos ojos frontales con sus dos
ojos frontales y además con tres de sus
otros ojos y además con tres de sus
otros ojos
ok qué fracción del número total de sus
ojos te está viendo y bueno aquí te
puedes dar cuenta que todas las arañas
tienen ocho ojos 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 1 2 3 4
5 6 y acá hay otros 2 7 8 y de igual
manera está tal vez te parezca un poco
débil ante todo esto pero enfoquémonos
en el problema si una araña común tiene
8 ojos y la araña te está viendo con sus
dos ojos frontales así que imagínate que
estás viendo con estos dos ojos con este
de aquí
y con este de aquí entonces qué fracción
representan sus dos ojos frontales
bueno pues tenemos ocho ojos que son la
cantidad total de ojos que tenemos y dos
de ellos los frontales está viendo ok ya
esto le tenemos que sumar otros tres
ojos que están viendo es lo que es el
problema además con tres de sus otros
ojos te están viendo así que imagínate
que te está viendo también con a este de
aquí con este de aquí y con este de acá
ok por lo tanto me voy a tomar tres de
sus otros ojos pero también recuerda que
tenemos ocho ojos totales y entonces
realmente lo que me tengo que tomar es
una suma de fracciones a cuánto es
iguales esto bueno pues lo padre es que
tenemos un denominador común nuestro
denominador común es 8 por lo tanto se
va a mantener y arriba que me queda
bueno pues arriba me quedan dos más 3
ya esto le voy a sumar a 3 que es la
cantidad de ojos que me están viendo en
total 23 porque tenemos el mismo
denominador es decir tenemos un
denominador común y esto es exactamente
lo mismo que 2 + 3 es 55 entre 8 por lo
tanto 5 de los 8 ojos que tiene esta
araña me están viendo además de tener un
problema bien sobre suma de fracciones
tenemos un problema espeluznante